[Music]
foreign
you used to have 10 to the ninth power
written in the corner of your notepad I
guess every week when you started at
Sequoia is that accurate and if so could
you explain why that's the case that is
accurate
when I joined Sequoia
it was clear that if if I wanted to make
it as a partner
you needed to produce meaningful gains
and I'd set myself the goal of producing
a billion dollars in gains for the
partnership because that would mean that
I'd I'd made it at some level and so 10
to the 9 which is a billion was my
shorthand of reminding myself what I was
striving for
now what was the notepad used for
otherwise and was this on the top of
every page or something you saw on a
weekly basis I'm wondering on these the
frequency with which you saw this and
also what the notepad was used for
otherwise
this notepad was used generally for
note-taking but it was really on Mondays
in particular when we had a partner
meeting where we would review all the
decisions for a particular day and that
would be the notepad where I'd make
notes about the companies that we were
listening to my own views on companies
what did I worry about what did I think
was interesting and so that was the most
important day at some level you know we
referred to it as the Olympic finals at
took away it was the Monday partner
meeting and the importance of getting
those decisions right and so that was
the day where I needed to remember very
acutely what was I striving for
so when I done this when I was younger
too I don't know if you'd heard this I
had and we're going to get to that okay
let me ask you before we before we flash
back and do the wavy Austin Powers
flashback to Childhood which I will do
in a minute with the 10 to the 9th did
you have in your mind a particular time
frame for that or was it just a reminder
of the magnitude of the goal before you
if you wanted to move the needle I
didn't really have a time to mention at
the time you know things have changed a
lot in the Venture business technology
has infused so much more of the world I
mean I I keep reminding myself when I
was at PayPal in 2000 there were about
200 million people on the planet that
had internet
200 million that's wild and the vast
majority of them were on dial-up
right so by the time I joined Sequoia in
2003 we we didn't even have Broadband
reaching 50 of the US population yet so
the numbers were still much smaller and
Technology didn't have the scale that it
does have today and so I just thought
eventually get to a billion now honestly
I feel like it's 10 to the 10 that you
need to strive for because you know
Technologies didn't fuse so much of what
we do
so let's do as promised the the rewind
to Childhood and I'll let you take this
ball and run with it wherever you want
to go but I did read a bit about your
high school system of having your goals
visible to you while you were studying
at least that's that's based on a bit of
reading I think this is actually from it
should be accurate because it's from
Sequoia cap.com or the Articles thereof
so could you please elaborate on what
you did
back during that era of your life
I thought I needed this concept in
Psychology called the Ulysses pact which
is this idea that you know in the birth
of Ulysses he wanted to hear the sirens
so he had all his soldiers always
Sailors wax up their ears time to a mast
and that way they could sell past and he
could hear the sirens
and they wouldn't succumb to them and so
in Psychology the Ulysses back is this
idea that you make a pact with your
future self knowing that your future
self is going to be weak and so my
technique for doing this not having read
about psychology yet was to put notes in
front of my desk on the door leaving my
room and candidly all over my room
reminding me what I was aiming for and
in high school that was to be the top 10
in my state at the end of high school at
College it was to be number one and I
would just put all these reminders of
what my goals were so if I was tempted
to get up to go make a cup of tea or
watch television or take a break I would
just see what I'd written to myself and
I'm reminded of what I need to do if I
want to achieve what I want to achieve
in life
do you still use reminders
like that of of of any type or or do you
feel like you've hit a certain escape
velocity where that's no longer
necessary
I still use some of those I mean when I
was at Sequoia you know as you pointed
out earlier I had the 10 to the nine
um I try to keep track of how I spend my
time uh when I was in college I would
literally write down the time that I
started studying down to the minute and
then I write down the time that I got up
so that I would have an accurate tally
at the end of the day of exactly how
much time I actually spent studying
instead of just thinking that I was
studying and just loafing around the
house doing nothing and so I use
Evernote to do that I I organize key
things that I want to accomplish for
Sequoia and for each of the companies
that I work with so I always have this
running list of what are the key things
you need to focus on the most important
the three most important things you need
to accomplish for a given company over
the next say six months as a reminder of
the most important things